how journalist going I'll tell I'll tell
you exactly how ready I want to write an
article about champagne that focuses on
the fact that prco from Italy is now a
good alternative for a portion of the
price I want you to historically
reference other times in history when
something was the establishment and a
product came along that was equal of
quality but a fraction of the price and
speak to it in a manner that helps
people understand that quality of flavor
is subjetive
but price is not enter the prompting I
just wrote a very good article for the
London Times about prco and champagne
something will be outputed and then I'm
going to read it and I'm going to add 10
more sentences and edit six more
sentences so the creativity of the
writer and the ability of the editor
becomes a new form of a human being I
just literally talked out to
you